Y
INDEPENDENCE.
WHEN WE HAVE CLEAN ENERGY.
ONE IS THAT GOING TO HAPPEN?
FIRST TONIGHT WITH JOE BIDEN
OBVIOUSLY COGNITIVELY IMPAIRED
AND STRUGGLING TO COMMUNICATE,
THE WHITE HOUSE JUST ROLLED OUT
A POPULAR ACTOR TO HELP WITH THE
MESSAGING SURROUNDING
GUN VIOLENCE.
TODAY UVALDE NATIVE MATTHEW
McCONAUGHEY, THE ACTOR, GAVE A
VERY EMOTIONAL SPEECH ABOUT THE
HORRIFIC SHOOTING IN HIS OWN
TOWN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IN THE REALITY OF WHAT
HAPPENED THAT DAY IN THE TOWN I
WAS BORN IN SET IN.
SO THE NEXT MORNING, MARK,
CAMILLA AND MYSELF SET OUT.
WHEN WE ARRIVED A FEW HOURS
LATER, I GOT TO TELL YOU, EVEN
FROM THE INSIDE OF OUR VEHICLE,
YOU COULD FEEL THE SHOCK IN THE
TOWN.
YOU COULD FEEL THE PAIN.
THE DENIAL, DISSOLUTION, ANGER,
BLAME, SADNESS, LOSS OF LIVES
AND DREAMS HALTED.
>> Sean: THAT PAIN IS REAL AND
IT'S HAPPENING WAY TOO OFTEN ON
THE COUNTRY.
TONIGHT WE DO CONTINUE TO PRAY
FOR THE FAMILIES AND UVALDE AND
EVERY OTHER CITY THAT WILL NEVER
BE THE SAME, ALONG WITH THE
FAMILIES OF MURDER VICTIMS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN MAJOR
CITIES LIKE CHICAGO, BALTIMORE,
L.A., NEW YORK, WE HAVE DOZENS
OF YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN, OUR
NATIONAL TREASURE, SHOT AND
KILLED EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
BUT WE RARELY HEAR ABOUT THIS
KIND OF VIOLENCE FROM DEMOCRATS,
WHICH IS WHERE THE POLITICAL
ASPECT COMES IN.
THEY ONLY SEEM TO REALLY CARE
ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE, ONLY WHEN IT
BECOMES POLITICALLY EXPEDIENT
FOR THEM.
KEEP IN MIND ALMOST ALL OF
AMERICA'S MOST VIOLENT CITIES
HAVE BEEN RULED BY DEMOCRATS FOR
DECADES AND EVERY ONE OF THOSE
CITIES HAS SOME OF THE STRICTEST
GUN CONTROL LAWS IN THE COUNTRY.
UNFORTUNATELY, DEMOCRATS, THEY
LOVE PASSING LAWS.
THEY JUST DON'T LIKE APPLYING
THEM TO DANGEROUS CRIMINALS.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THEY HAVE 0-BARREL LAWS, LACKS
PROSECUTION, SHORT SENTENCING
GUIDELINES, DEFUNDING,
DISMANTLING THE POLICE, ALL
DIRECTLY CONTRIBUTING TO THE
CARNAGE IN ALL OF THESE CITIES,
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE DOESN'T SEEM
TO CARE.
THEY DON'T EVEN BRING IN
CELEBRITIES TO GIVE IMPASSIONED
SPEECHES ABOUT THE DETERIORATION
OF BALTIMORE, AND THEY SHOULD.
THERE ARE NO DRAMATIC CALLS FOR
ACTION AFTER A VIOLENT WEEKEND
IN CHICAGO.
CHRONICLING ALL OF THAT SINCE
2009 AND SCROLLING NAMES ON THIS
PROGRAM.
YOU NEVER HEAR JOE BIDEN
SCREAMING FOR LAWMAKERS, FOR GOD
SAKES, DO SOMETHING AFTER
ANOTHER ROUND OF SHOOTINGS IN
L.A., AND BY THE WAY, YOU'RE
NEVER GOING TO HEAR DEMOCRAT
TALKING ABOUT THE 2.5 MILLION
DEFENSIVE GUN USES EACH YEAR.
THEY RESULT IN COUNTLESS LIVES
BEING SAVED.
FOR THE LEFT, THIS ISN'T ABOUT
SAVING LIVES OR INDUCING
VIOLENCE.
LIKE ALWAYS, IT IS POLITICAL AND
IT IS AN EMOTIONAL PLOY TO
CENTRALIZE THEIR POWER OVER
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
AND BY THE WAY, MANY OF THEM
WOULD LIKE TO USURP ALL
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
BUT GOT TO PROTECT HER
CONSTITUTION AND OUR RIGHT TO
DEFEND OURSELVES.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT MATTHEW
McCONAUGHEY, I BELIEVE, WITH
ALL MY HEART, HE HAD GOOD
INTENTIONS TODAY, AND TO HIS
CREDIT, HE WANTS TO HELP.
I GIVE HIM A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
THAT.
HE ALSO SAID THINGS ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH.
DEMOCRATS HAVE SHOWN THOUGH OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THEY DON'T CARE
IF THEY IGNORED THE WEEKLY
VIOLENCE IN DEMOCRATIC-RUN
CITIES AND STATES WE ONLY HEAR
FROM THEM WHEN THEY BELIEVE THEY
CAN POLITICIZE THIS EVENT OR
THAT EVENT AND IGNORE ALL THE
WEEKLY VIOLENCE THAT TAKES PLACE
IN THE CITIES THAT THEY'VE BEEN
RUNNING, AND IT'S VERY SAD.
YOU KNOW WHAT, SINCE 2009 WE
HAVE SCROLLED NAME AFTER NAME
AFTER NAME AFTER NAME AFTER
NAME, PEOPLE YOU NEVER HEAR OF,
PEOPLE THEY NEVER TALK ABOUT
KILLED IN CHICAGO, SHOT IN
CHICAGO, NEW YORK, L.A., AND
THEY HAVEN'T LIFTED A FINGER.
IF BARELY MENTIONED IT.
JOE BIDEN BARELY MENTIONED IT,
EIGHT YEARS AS VICE PRESIDENT.
AND TODAY THEY WERE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO HIDE BEHIND A VERY
WELL-LIKED AFTER WHO TO ME
SEEMED TO HAVE VERY SINCERE
INTENTIONS.
HE GAVE A VERY IMPASSIONED
SPEECH ADVOCATING FOR NEW GUN
LAWS.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> WE KNOW WHAT'S ON THE TABLE.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN MENTAL
HEALTH CARE.
WE NEED SAFER SCHOOLS.
WE NEED TO RESTRAIN
SENSATIONALIZED MEDIA COVERAGE.
WE NEED TO RESTORE OUR FAMILY
VALUES, WE NEED TO RESTORE OUR
AMERICAN VALUES AND...
WE NEED RESPONSIBLE GUN
OWNERSHIP RESPONSIBLE GUN
OWNERSHIP.
WE NEED BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WE NEED TO RAISE THE MINIMUM AGE
TO PURCHASE AN AR-15 RIFLE.
221.
WE NEED AWAITING PERIOD FOR
THOSE RIFLES, WE NEED RED FLAG
LAWS AND CONSEQUENCES FOR THOSE
WHO ABUSE THEM.
>> Sean: AND A FOLLOW-UP
INTERVIEW RIGHT ON FOX, HE GAVE
HIS TAKE ON THE CURRENT
NEGOTIATIONS ON CAPITOL HILL,
AND HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> YOU HAD A NUMBER OF TALKS ON
CAPITOL HILL.
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS IS THE
TIME?
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS IS
SOMEHOW DIFFERENT?
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS
BEFORE.
>> YES.
>> I COVERED A LOT OF THEM.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
COMPARE IT TO UP HERE ON THE
HILL, BUT THE CONSENSUS WORD
THAT I'M HEARING IS THAT THIS
TIME IS DIFFERENT, THAT THERE IS
SOME MORE MOMENTUM THAT ON THE
RIGHT THERE ARE SOME THINGS THEY
ARE WILLING TO NOT STAUNCHLY SAY
NO TO AND CONSIDER AND I'M ON
THE LEFT THERE WILLING TO SAY,
YOU KNOW WHAT, WE MAY WANT THE
WHOLE LOAF, BUT WE WILL TAKE A
SLICE.
>> Sean: AS HE JUST SAID,
DEMOCRATS ARE CONTENT TO GET A
SLICE NOW, THEN, WHAT, ANOTHER
SLICE NEXT YEAR, THEN ANOTHER
AND ANOTHER AND ANOTHER UNTIL
THEY HAVE TH